what i hope to do in this video is look
at this graph y is equal to f of x and
think about the intervals where this
graph is positive or negative and then
think about the intervals when this
graph is increasing or decreasing
so first let's just think about when is
this function
when is this function positive
well positive means that the value of
the function is greater than zero it
means that the value of the function is
what means that the function is sitting
above the x-axis so it's sitting above
the x-axis in this place right over here
that i am highlighting in yellow
and it is also
sitting above the x-axis
over here
and if we wanted to if we wanted to
write those intervals mathematically
let's see let's say that this point
let's say that this this point right
over here is x equals a
let's say that this right over here is x
equals b
and this right over here is x equals
c
then it's positive
it's positive as long as x is between a
and b at x equals a or at x equals b the
value of our function is zero but it's
positive when x is
between a and b
a
and b
or if x is greater than c
x is we could write it there c is less
than x or we could write that x is
greater
than c
these are the intervals when when our
function is positive let me write this f
of x
f of x positive when x is in this
interval or this interval or that
interval
so when is f of x negative
let me just another c another color f of
x is going to be
negative
well it's going to be negative if x is
less than a
so this is if x is less than a or if x
is between b and c then we see that f of
x is below the x axis f of x
is down here so this is where it's
negative
so here or
or x is between b or c
b
x is between b and c and i'm not saying
less than or equal to because if at at b
or c the value of the function f of b is
zero f of c is zero that's where we are
actually intersecting the x axis so
that's that was reasonably
straightforward now let's ask ourselves
a different question when is the
function increasing or decreasing so
when is f of x
f of x
in
increasing
well increasing one way to think about
it is for every time that x is
increasing then y should be increasing
or another way to think about it you
have you have a
you have a positive rate of change of y
with respect to x so you could even
think about it as imagine if you had a
if you had a tangent line at any of
these points if you had a tangent line
at any of these points the slope of that
tangent line is going to be is going to
be positive but the easiest way for me
to think about it is as you increase x
you're going to be increasing y
so where is the function increasing well
i'm doing it
in blue so it's increasing
right until we get to this
this point right over here
right until we get to that point over
there
and then it starts decreasing until we
get to this point right over here and
then it starts increasing again
it starts
increasing again
so let me make some more let me make
some more labels here so let's say that
this
this is x equals d and then this right
over here actually let me do that green
color
so let's say
this is
x equals d now it's not a d b but you
can get the picture and let's say that
this is x is equal to
x is equal to let me do it a little bit
x is equal to e
x is equal to e so when is this function
increasing well it's increasing if x is
less than d x is less than d
and i'm not going to say less than or
equal to because right at x equals d it
looks like
just for that moment the slope of the
tangent line looks like it would be it
would be constant we're going from
increasing to decreasing so right at d
we're neither increasing or decreasing
but then we're also increasing
so if x is less than d
or x is greater than e
and where is f of x decreasing
so
f x let me just in a different color
when is
let me pick a
move
so f of x
decreasing
decreasing well it's going to be right
over here it's going to be right between
d
and e between x equals d and x equals z
but not exactly at those points because
at both of those points you're neither
increasing nor decreasing but you see
right over here as x increases as you
increase your x what's happening to your
y if you go from this point and you
increase your x what happened to your y
your y has decreased you increase your x
y has decreased to increase x
y has decreased all the way until this
point over here
so f x is decreasing for x between
d
and e
so hopefully that that gives you a sense
of things notice these aren't the same
intervals that we are the the intervals
where we're positive or negative don't
perfectly coincide with when we are
increasing or decreasing so it's very
important to think about these
separately even though they kind of
sound the same